[Music]
all right so it's a it's it's a real
pleasure today to have our own sandy
Chang I know that some of you are on the
mailing list we're expecting to see an
ricky de la cruz he had a family
emergency and had to cancel but he will
be on the list for this next fall sandy
is the associate dean for science in
Yale College science education he was an
undergraduate here at Yale
I'm embarrassed to say that he took
chemistry when I was a junior faculty
member here so that makes me feel like
I've been here a long long long time
that I potentially could have had sandy
in class
sandy guys BS in 88 went to Cornell
Medical School he'll tell you more about
his background he's been a faculty
member at our medical school for some
time now and as I'm sure you're all
excited to hear he's going to tell us
today about the telomere cancer
connection so join me in welcoming
professor sandy Chang
[Applause]
Thank You Kurt for that nice
introduction and welcome all of you to
yellow sign Saturday let's see this
works okay so I hope of some of you at
least got to see the demonstration I had
outside when I had set up three
microscopes looking in normal cells and
through my scope looking at cancer cells
and I just wanted you to know for those
of you who didn't get to see it we
actually looked at cancer cells for my
person named Henrietta Lacks some of you
may know this name Henrietta Lacks
was an african-american lady who
unfortunately died from cervical cancer
in 1951 but her contribution to science
is immense because her cells list even
though she died her cancer cells was
biopsied put in a dish and they grew her
cells were the first human cancer cells
to grow no other human cancer cells in
the past was able to be grown in the
dish so she was my age thing so this is
Henrietta Lacks if you want to know more
about her this is a fantastic book
written by Rebecca Skloot the mortal
lives of Henrietta Lacks so we got to
see her cells which I use a lot in my
own laboratory versus normal cells okay
so before I go I want to see in a show
of hands how many high school students
are in the audience
high school students raise your hands up
okay a few high school students up a
middle school Oh mostly middle schools
elementary school we have a few - all
right great
now I'm the type of professor who love
to ask questions and I want to hear
answers okay so don't be shy about raise
your hand and answering my questions and
in fact it would be a special prize
though for the student who answers the
most questions I'm not gonna tell you
what prize it is you have to wait for it
all right so I'm gonna talk a little bit
about me and my career as a scientist so
I was born in Taiwan and I came to us
when I was seven years old I grew up in
New York City in the Bronx and I went to
an amazing high school called a Bronx
High School sign some of you may have
heard of it Bronx icicle science it
generates a lot of scientists but it
doesn't only do science okay so I don't
want to give you that impression so I
did a lot of science fair project
as a student and this is me 34 years ago
when I did a project in astronomy I
actually build a telescope hook they
detected to it and look at the light
curves of these stars called variable
stars and figured out that they change
the light shape because they have a big
star spot on them you know the Suns have
sunspots right these stars have
humongous sunspots i covering quarter of
their surface of their of their sphere
so when the star rotates that the light
comes up and down and I use my telescope
to actually make a light curve out of it
I was fortunate enough to be selected as
one of the 40 finalists and it was
called a Science Talent Search now it's
called a Regeneron Science Talent Search
and this is us in Washington DC we
actually got to meet President Reagan in
those days this is me right here and the
cool thing about being in a science fair
is not just the science that you do but
the people that you meet so these are my
fellow Science Talent Search winner
these are the New York winners and we
got to meet all these Nobel laureates so
this is Leon Lederman this is going
Seaborg these are Nobel laureates in
particle physics so they imparted a lot
of very useful and advice to a junior
scientist so as fortunate to be selected
a second-place winner
I've won a $10,000 scholarship to Yale
which in those days was a pretty good
money right ten thousand dollars now the
prize money is $250,000 for a
first-place winner so you kids if you
get one of these prizes you're fit your
parents will be very very happy because
they could go you guys could go to
college without them paying a cent right
so this is me in my glory days but I
still do astronomy in my spare time this
is my observatory in my backyard that I
built myself you could see that I got QB
tracks and here's my telescope so I go
out on a clear night and do my thing I
still do there was very variable star
astronomy and actually my daughter has
done some of this as well with me so I'm
very happy about that but I am NOT an
astronomer so that goes that's the one
thing I want to tell you is you could be
interested in many different phases of
science you don't necessarily have to do
it as a profession in fact if you do it
as a career as a hobby it's even better
there's no pressure to actually produce
you we just have fun doing it
okay so what else did I do like i skirt
told you I was a Yale student I just sat
right over there 30 years ago taking
general chemistry and organic chemistry
right in this very room and I major in
molecular biophysics and biochemistry
which is the major that if you come in
as a Yale student I think is a really
amazing major you learn to do molecular
biochemistry and I worked in Yale Labs
is the undergraduate then I had more to
say about that then I went to a combined
degree program I'm an MD PhD that means
I have an MD degree and a PhD degrees
I'm a physician scientist so this is
actually a very cool combined degree
program it's a seven year program that
gives you both degrees and it's
absolutely free it's very competitive to
do but many of our Yale students get
into these programs all right so don't
cost any money you don't have you you're
not in debt coming out of medical school
as a doctor so I had a lot of other
training after getting my degrees after
seven years and I went to do a residency
in pathology over at Harvard Medical
School so I trained as a doctor I'm
still a doctor I still see patient
samples climb a pathology I don't see
patients per se and I also trained for
more science I want to allow to learn
how to to do more science and this is
the science I'm going to tell you about
today which is telomere biology so more
straining scientists and then I came to
Yale came back to Yale in 2010 as a
professor so I'm professor in school
medicine I recently became the Dean of
stem education at York College so for
those of you who don't know what a
genius the Dean is just a guy who gives
a lot of advice okay so I'm gonna give
you students some advice as we go along
in this you know progression today so my
first advice for those of you who are
interested in doing science is that it's
great for you guys to come here to
listen to scientists talk like like me
but to do science you got to go and do
it
okay you gotta go and do science fair
projects I think those are the those are
the ways for you to really get involved
in doing science so for the middle
school students I suggest you
to your science teachers very interested
and do a project there's so many cool
projects now on the internet to get for
you guys to get ideas many more sources
of you know to get science ideas and
when I was a student so talk to your
science teachers about doing a science
fair project and the Connecticut science
fair is a great venue for you guys to
present your science fair research and
in fact you could you could even make
prizes you can make our money anybody
here have done Connecticut science fairs
okay so one so I want to see more hands
go up as as we as we progress so for the
high school students in the audience I
want to give you a tip and my tip is if
you're over 16 years of age you can
actually come to Yale to work as a as a
summer student you just have to pester
that Yale professor that you're
interested in working with email that
person over and over to get your foot
into the door okay now your chances of
getting into a Yale lab is greater if
you start doing some science for your
project in middle school then you're
gonna build a progression the
professor's gonna say hey you know this
kid is done a lot of cool science fair
projects he's interested in science and
he's shown bye-bye all these projects
done maybe I'll give him a chance but or
her him or her a chance by bringing him
or her into the lab okay so 60 years of
age come to Yale to do a project with a
professor and then you can enter your
project into one of these contests I did
my project on my own but that's kind of
rare these days so if you want to work
in a Yale lab it's a very good thing to
do and the other advice I want to tell
you is if you're interested in becoming
a scientist go to a college this is what
high school juniors or seniors applying
to college go to a college that
emphasizes undergraduate science
research especially a place that will
give you money to do research a lot of
colleges don't do this so you have to do
a little homework and it doesn't really
matter what college you go to
what matters is that you go to the best
graduate school so four years of
undergraduate if you do a lot of
research it doesn't matter if you come
to Yale or to another school but if you
do a lot of undergraduate research and
you can get into the best graduate
school that's important
okay so that's my advice okay so I want
to talk to you about my about my
research but I want to use a patient of
mine as the segue so this is a real
patient I'm not gonna tell you her name
we heard just in this shows LC when I
met LC she was only 15 years old okay
much like what you guys are many of you
are 15 years old two months before her
16 year old birthday she starts feeling
tired she's normally a very healthy
person she used to run marathons
why does she become tired all of a
sudden she can't even walk to the ends
of her driveway and then she start
developing these little blotches on her
skin okay and then what really got her
scared is when she start brushing her
teeth she started bleeding profusely
right normally when you brush your teeth
you shouldn't believe so it's her teeth
started bleeding and then came to the
doctor and that's how I saw her so what
are you guys thinking I want this all my
my th students scientists start thinking
so what are you guys thinking what do
you think has happened to LC yes kid
over there why do you think cancer all
of a sudden this is a 50 year old 15
year old don't get cancer yes when
you're talking to speak up loud okay
this pocket see that this is a very
clever kid this talk is about cancer so
I'm gonna talk about a patient with
cancer okay very good
yeah yes so why would why would you
suspect him sir if the kid is bleeding
excessively why love not climbing do you
hear this kid she said blood not cloudy
that's why you start bleeding profusely
that's a very good sign so what test do
you want to do what easy test would you
want to do with this LC she's at your
clinic you're you guys are doctors
what easy tests yes speak up
blood tests exactly you do it very easy
you pit you you make a pinprick
put it on top on a sly make a smear this
is what her smear looks like this is a
normal blood smear red blood cells white
blood cells look at Elsie's blood smear
what do you think here what do these are
these normal cells do they look normal
to you do they look like these cells
these are neutrophils these are normal
white blood cells are fighting infection
do we see any of the you guys here we
see these crazy tell me their size are
they big small they're big they're giant
they're big giant cells
okay good very good you guys go up eat
pathologists fantastic all right so let
me tell you a little bit about how blood
cells mature okay normally you have
something called a myeloblast which is a
stem cell don't worry about the name you
know the thing in science is just a lot
of names okay don't worry so much about
the name just think about the constant
so anyway this myeloblast turned into
what's called a promoter site does this
cell look like anything in your saw LLC
cells right and this promoter site then
go through all these things and they've
become a neutrophil okay so why do you
guys think we only see this promoter
site in LC cells but not all these
normal cells what happened they call
people that haven't raised it yes
you got a thunk up okay that's a good
talk but that's not exactly what's
happening they're not all for me
together about that kid right there yeah
yes you
I'm sorry I can't hear you gotta speak
up they're not functioning as they're
supposed to exactly so instead of
turning into neutrophils l see cells are
stuck on the promoter side stage you
don't make any other cells that's all
you see is these type of cells okay and
she has what's called a Q promyelocytic
leukemia she has leukemia somebody here
said over there is absolutely right she
has leukemia she has a blood cancer very
very scary disease this used to be fatal
30 years ago if you have this disease
you are dead 100% death and 15 years of
age that's a very sad prognosis luckily
this is a very rare disease okay so with
LC will something helps something
happens that just the normal
differentiation I'm you're gonna throw a
few words out there the appreciation
means the changes from this cell to this
cell differentiation is blocked the
normally where you go from this white
blood cell blast the myeloblast to
neutrophil you go through these stages
but this is block right at the
promyelocytes stage so the question is
why why does this happen okay so let's
let's explore this question a very
famous scientists look at the
chromosomes of patients with acute
promyelocytic leukemia chromosomes are
units of genetic material for those of
you who don't know we have 23
chromosomes from your mom 23 chromosome
from your dad
if you look at the chromosomes what's in
every acute promyelocytic leukemia is a
switch between chromosome 15 and 17 it's
called a 1517 translocation chromosome
15 breaks chromosome 17 breaks they
switch places here's 15 here's 17 break
break switch places now you get a hybrid
chromosome 15 and a hybrid chromosome 17
this is not good and this is
Gnostic for this disease all acute
promyelocytic leukemia have this type of
translocation the chromosomes break and
switch places okay so let's go one step
further asked why this happens so what
happens when chromosomes so chromosomes
are where genes live you could think
about chromosomes as a library it's a
library of your genetic information the
books in the library are the genes okay
so think about if you take a library you
have two libraries from two different
towns if you chop them in half and put
the libraries together maybe sometimes
you're gonna chop a book in half you're
gonna chop a gene in having you're gonna
stitch two genes that are nothing to do
with each other together and that's
exactly what happened with LC so
chromosome 17 normally encodes a gene
that makes a protein called retinoic
acid receptor alpha okay don't worry
again about the name just remember that
chromosome something has a gene a blue
gene chromosome 15 has a gene has
multiple colors it's called promising
leukemia gene all of those genes have
normal functions they held the monocytes
to differentiate into neutrophils that's
their function of these genes what
happens with LC and all patients is AP
ml q Promaster leukemia is that there's
a break here and there's a break here
and you get a weird gene I made what's
called a fusion gene the fusion gene
will make a fusion protein which is a
cancerous protein this protein is a new
protein only arising from this switch
this translocation and this protein
blocks differentiation okay because
remember I told you normally these two
genes are involved in differentiation
now you chop them in half make a new
gene it's not gonna work so that's why
these cells cannot differentiate they're
stuck in the promyelocytes stage if
you're stuck in a primal acai stays like
like the woman the girl in the pattern
of their said you can't make white blood
cells you can't make platelets that's
why you start bleeding because you can't
make normal cells right normal blood
cells are needed to
stop bleeding stop infection so what do
you think about Elsi chance of getting
infections is a high or low very high
right she had no neutrophils a file of
infections that's what this is a bad
disease so what I want to impress with
you is this is a disease in which
there's actually a break in genes in DNA
and that's what cancer is cancer is a
disease of the genes cancer is a genetic
disease all cancers are due to mutations
in genes in all these cases particularly
these two genes yes that's a great
question this is not random 15:17
translocation is characteristic of this
disease I'm going to tell you why this
is in my later in my talk okay
so like I said this new cancer protein
that's generated from this break and
then joining blocks differentiation so
normal cellular differentiation is
blocked in patients with acute
promyelocytic leukemia but thank
goodness there is cure okay I wouldn't
be here talking to you there's no cure
it so happens that a drug or trans no
trans rectal cancer or atra can actually
bind to this cancer protein and blocks
it this is research done totally
serendipitously people were testing
different compounds that you know what
they were doing and just came upon this
just by chance in the seventies and
amazingly it works
so all transdermal access changes the
the stock promyelocytes and then allows
them to differentiate back into
neutrophils and this is a drug that was
given to all AP ml patients and it is
curative yes yeah
speak up
that's a great question so neutrophils
are white blood cells so all the white
blood cell lineage yet gets blocked
there's other two pathways in in blood
formation is now blocked it's not just
neutrophils
so with Elsie's case she was cured this
is one instance when a drug can actually
cure pit she hasn't been on this truck
forever and thank goodness there's
little side effects with this drug and
now she's a mom which is fantastic
but this case illustrates again the
cancer is a genetic disease right cancer
is the disease of the DNA that's what
people say you shouldn't go out to the
UV you don't want to you know be exposed
to the ionizing radiation because UV
light mutates DNA
similarly gene breaks gene fusions also
caused cancer like you see with whoops
with with Elsie's case and another thing
that I want to emphasize is you don't
have to kill cancer cells to treat them
so a lot of cases when you're with
radiation therapy with chemotherapy the
aim is to kill cancer cells don't
necessarily have to do that anymore if
you could change a cancer cells biology
to make it differentiate into normal
cells that's the same thing right the
cancer is not completely gone she still
has the cancer cells around it's just
being suppressed by this drug and it's
not affecting the normal cellular
function of white blood cells yes you
have a question can this be passed down
to children that's a great question
so is this mutate so how do you get a
cancerous passed out to children where
does the mutation have to be which gene
what are what cells in any gene only in
the germ cells in the sperm cells or in
the egg cells only those mutations do
you get passed down to kids her mutation
is in non germ cell so she will not pass
this down to her kids but that's a
really good question
other questions yes
yes she has to constantly take this job
because this protein still be made
you're not getting rid of this protein
you're just blocking this protein from
from its evil functions so unfortunately
you shall have to take this drug but
that's picking this drug is better than
dying yes let's talk about breast cancer
by but 2 percent of breast cancer is
inherited most of the breast cancers are
not inherited cannot be passed down yes
[Music]
he's asking a very sophisticated
question between meiosis and mitosis
these breaks are non mitotic these are
mitotic breaks ok they're not dissimilar
breaks mitotic breaks are different and
they don't involve 1517 but that's a
very good question that's the breaks
mechanism are similar which I'm going to
get into ok so I have to have to go on
so if I were just a doctor I'll be happy
with just treating the patient right I
give a I'll see the drug she's living
and she's she's fine
but as a scientist I'm not satisfied
because scientist is always asking why
so the question is why do breaks happen
right that should be like I'm a regular
mind why are breaks happening why do
gene fusions cause cancer ok so that's
the question I wanted to address so to
address this question you have to wait
to go to another topic which is a thing
called telomeres this is are going to be
the focus of my talk telomeres are these
structures at the ends of all of our
chromosomes in fact there are the ends
of every eukaryotic organism they're
composed of long stretches of DNA that
encodes a repetitive sequence ttaggg
that's repeated thousands of times
ttaggg
tthe g ttaggg just keeps on going okay
and so this is a chromosome like I
showed you before and telomeres are
there at the ends so here's the agreeing
our telomere DNA and these are telomeric
sequences
okay so just remember that and telomeres
you could think of if you don't remember
anything remember this slide telomeres
are the ends of like like the little
plastic caps at the ends of your
shoelace okay
you can somebody in the street randomly
ask you what's a telomere you could say
there's a little plastic capsule in its
my shoelace they protect my shoelaces
and make it functional which is exactly
what they do so here is caps of the
inner shoe lace but you need them to
thread them into the holes of your
sneaker if they've become frayed without
the cap your shoelaces are messed up and
we call those this functional so
telomeres when they become dysfunctional
are no longer functioning okay they
don't have a proper function so think of
telomeres - the ends of your shoelaces
over they're no longer functional they
don't exert the normal cellular function
so I'm going to tell you what telomeres
do and why is this important in thinking
about Elsie's cancer
okay so telomeres are as I said it's
about chromosomes but because of I'm not
going to explain why but because of
these weird things that happen normal
cells when they divide they cannot copy
the ends of telomeres okay that's just
that this is what's happened in
eukaryotic cells so what happens when
the cell divides over time is that the
telomeres get shorter and shorter and
shorter you can think of telomeres or as
a biological clock in fact look at your
parents around you they have shorter
telomeres than you guys do right because
they've lived longer they have many more
rounds of cell division okay so in 99%
of our cells telomeres are shortening
our skin cells our organs our you know
cells are divided only in our stem cells
do telomeres are maintained and they're
maintained by this enzyme called
telomerase which is shown here
telomerase is the enzyme that maintains
telomere ends this is the immortal
enzyme if you have telomerase in
yourselves your cells will never never
die they will just keep on the body for
ever and ever and ever and ever
okay and it's because telomerase
prevents telomeres from shortening if
you don't sure your telomeres you could
divide forever I'm going to
you why in a second so this is telomers
and remember alarm race is only in 1
percent of ourselves you just stem cells
but in 90% of our cancer cells 90
percent of all our cancer cells Express
telomerase because cancer cells as you
probably know divide like crazy they're
immortal because they grow grow grow
grow they don't stop until either you
die or you do something to kill it
that's why these cases are so lethal
because they're immortal and the reason
why they're immortal is because they
turn on those enzyme telomerase to
maintain telomere ends so it is utterly
important for every organism to maintain
your telomere ends you can't live with
your telomeres and I'm going to tell you
why
ok so how do we look at telomere length
telomere length and different
chromosomes are have different sizes so
we could run them we could chop the
telomeres up with an enzyme run it on a
what's called a gel so you can separate
our telomere length by size and what you
actually get is a smear ok so here's a
representation here's a chromosome
here's telomere the two ends of a
chromosome they get shorter as I said as
you divide cellular division right
parents your chili meals are getting
shorter unfortunately a grandparents the
telomeres are right down here ok
nearest senescence so in essence is the
face of the cells when they stop
dividing
ok I'm going to tell you more about
senescence so here's cell division T let
me Oh getting shorter so here's a smear
you look at telomeres like this they get
shorter shorter shorter and then here in
cancer cells they don't get anymore
shorter but they don't get longer
either they reactivate telomerase and
maintain the telomeres that a stable or
short length okay so if you look at
normal human cells these against somatic
cells no column Reese look these are
white blood cells if you look at people
from sixty to a hundred years of age
look at the telomere length you can see
yes indeed they did telomeres do sure
about 70 base pairs per year
okay so again telomere length can be
used as a biological clock a clock of
aging okay so I'm gonna link this
concept of cancer aging together in a
second
so now we know telomere shortening all
of us except for our stem cell so if you
were to look at stem cell telomere
length what would you get who's smart
what street lighting what up it up and
down like this really a cross very good
so you get so steamed cell telomere
length would be like this right because
they don't Shirin over it over time
because they express what do stem cells
Express make their telomeres long no
they do divide but they express
telomerase the enzyme telomerase to
maintain the telomeres okay okay good so
what is the consequence of short
telomeres gene fusions chromosomes are
sticking to each other this is one of
the reasons why chromosome fusions occur
in a patient like LC sure telomeres
causes chrome so here's one chromosome
in blue okay these red dots are
telomeres but if you have short
telomeres the telomeres scarce so sure
you don't see a red dot but they start
sticking to each other so these are the
chromosome fusions that we see in LCD
the translocation that we saw with 1517
here we have a lot of translocation
kisaki I experimental showing the
telomeres down in these cells by a great
deal so you can see here these
chromosome like this problems are very
short here we see these two little red
dot it's smaller than these two that so
these telomeres have shorter than these
and the shortest ones have started
sticking to your lower fusion so sure
telomeres causes gene fusions yes
[Music]
okay so the 90% of cancer cells
reactivate this enzyme polymerase so
remember I said that the telomere is
really really short then they turn on
telomerase and they keep their Chi let
me ask you up or no shorter so it's okay
to live with your short telomeres as
long as you don't get any shorter to
activate all the bad responses we I'm
going to talk about in a second so
cancer cells all turn on this gene
called telomerase the enzyme is working
to maintain telomeres so that's why
they're immortal okay why don't
regularly turn on telomerase that's a
really great question and the reason is
because we are long live organisms we
have long live organism one of the
drawbacks is that we get cancer so
Nature has evolved a way to make us not
get cancer very frequently by getting
rid of telomerase and most of ourselves
because remember I said Clym rate
expression is associated with cancer so
we know expressed farmers in ourselves
because we age we accumulate mutations
if you have telomerase in your cells you
can get cancer very easily at a young
age we don't want that so this is a
byproduct of the fact that we are a
group of beings that age for a long time
we have long live organisms yes
now that's such a great question you
guys are asking amazing questions so in
sum I'm going to tell you about why so
can you hold that question for a second
that is a fantastic question okay so I
taught you the short telomeres causes
gene fusions I'm never gonna finish our
talk with all these questions these are
amazing questions so this is what's
happening
okay I'm gonna link short telomeres with
cancer so if you have short telomeres
with advancing age you're gonna get gene
Fuji chromosome fusions because your
telomeres fuse that's a by hallmark and
fused chromosomes are very unstable they
only go the cycle in which the
chromosome could get broken and repaired
called fusion fusion breakage braids a
bridge cycle so the the chromosomes are
fused then they get pulled apart when
the cell divides they get broken and all
of this causes cancer to form because it
makes again translocations between two
potential cancer-causing genes and they
form what's called carcinoma in situ
this is an early form of cancer most of
the kids that cannot progress beyond
this early form of cancer called
carcinoma in situ in fact if all of you
all of us older people may already have
carcinoma sites we just don't know it
because they develop and nothing happens
they don't get any worse the reason is
because carcinoma statues don't turn on
the enzyme telomerase remember I said 90
percent of human cancer after turn on
telomerase only when you turn on
telomerase do you become an amazing
aggressive invasive cancer that's when
cancer kills you not when assisting your
colon and form a little nodule that
doesn't kill you cancer kills you
because it because metastatic and
invades and it goes to your brain and
gives you a stroke and you die okay
or it goes to some other organ and just
blocks organ function that's why cancer
isn't when this becomes invasive it's
very bad that's what you have to do ne
or checkups like be any check with
hopefully a catch cancer at this early
stage you could get rid of it but at
this stage is very hard to get rid of
yes
slumbrous I know there's a lot of lingo
that sounds very similar I wonder who's
gonna ask that question so the 10% of
cancers that don't activate telomerase
they activate another program to
maintain telomeres okay though that's a
program that salami is independent
there's another way to make chili meals
longer I'm not gonna go into it today
because it's very complicated I actually
studied this in my lab as well but it
doesn't require two llamas and in fact
the most aggressive brain cancer
glioblastoma multiforme II in the brain
activates that program so some of our
most aggressive cancers activated
telomere maintenance program that
doesn't require timers but 100% of all
human cancers have to activate a
telomere maintenance program you've got
to maintain your telomeres like I said
short telomeres kills you so 90% turn on
telomerase 10% do this thing called
alternative lengthening of telomeres or
alt telomers independence I'll be happy
to talk to you more about after after
this lecture if you want alright so now
I'm going to talk about the flip side of
so we talked all about telomerase
telomeres a cancer I want to talk a
little bit about aging okay so if you
look at cells if you take normal human
fibroblasts normal human skin cells and
put it in a dish and grow it do you
think they D cells will grow forever
like the HeLa cells that we saw outside
why do you think they won't grow forever
yes
yes so you have been listening right so
these cells have short telomeres they
get ineffective exactly what happens so
when this the scientist named Leonard
hayflick did this experiment in the
1950s he took normal human fibroblasts
out put it in a dish grew it and he
thought you know normal human fireblast
is gonna act just like HeLa cells
remember I just told you that HeLa cells
grow and grow and grow they grow forever
these things don't grow forever they
only grow to be about 60 passages you
could transfer them to 60 plates and
that's it then they stop dividing so
look at these cells these cells are
pretty healthy right here the nuclei
they look like they're pretty good shape
what do you think about these cells they
look like what I loved teaching this
class in fact that's what we call it an
egg a fried egg morphology they do look
like fried eggs in fact sometimes they
have by nucleated cells that look like
they have two egg yolks okay
these are what's called senescence cells
senescence cells are cells that don't
divide anymore they can't about because
they're very short telomeres and in fact
you know for us older people that's what
we've been getting in our organs where
you're accumulating senescence cells as
we age okay so what is the linkage
between senescence cells and aging and
the linkage is because aging is
completely do my complete I don't want
to say completely because there's other
causes of aging but aging is 90% due to
the accumulation of senescence cells and
large part of the senescence cells come
from short telomeres there are other
ways to get senescence cells and what
tell you in a second but aging is
because we are organs that normally
function so well for 6070 years so
failing us why do they fail us because
the normal cells keep on doing this the
normal cells that are normally
functioning well every time they divide
their till amazing any shorter so you're
accumulating senescence cells as we age
you know accumulation of maybe 10 20 %
of senescence else is okay
but if the number of senescence cells
like say your heart is too much your
organs are gonna stop working less well
that's that's a sign of aging aging is
really defined and when your organs
don't work so well right your skin is
not working so well okay young person
skilled versus an old person skin
dramatic difference right and there's
increased cancer in older people as well
so in senescence it's really due to DNA
damage and telomere like I said
shortening it's just a form of DNA
damaged DNA damaging you come from
getting the Sun to give you too much of
the sunlight you get too much IR
radiation chemo therapeutic
unfortunately one of the side effects of
getting cancer treatment is that you age
because the chemotherapy is damaging
cancer genes cancer cells genes but it's
also damaged your normal genes
chemotherapy doesn't distinguish the old
fashioned chemotherapy doesn't
distinguish normal from cancer cells
it's just cancer cells are more
sensitive to the chemo agents you're
still killing the normal stem cells
that's why you vomit that's where you
lose your hair right you no more stem
cells are gone so chemotherapeutics our
back is the damaged DNA cancer-causing
genes oxidative stress and you're the
oxygen that we breathe it's not a good
thing anyway so all of these things
cause DNA damage and DNA damage it's
read out by another thing I want to tell
you keep in mind it's a protein called
p53 protein 53 the P stands for protein
this is a very important protein I want
you guys to remember this protein as
well p53 is the guardian of the genome
it's like the sensor it senses DNA
damage and it tells the cells okay you
have too much damage I'm gonna shut you
down and the way to get shut down is to
go into a senescent program
remember assists in that sense that
happens when in a normal fiberglass you
get trap asses 60 times that you get
short telomeres and short telomeres a
function just as a damaged DNA damaged
activating p53 then bring you into the
skin sa so senescence normally a good
thing senescence is the anti-cancer
program that eukaryotes have evolved
okay the drawback of senescence in aging
but it's better to age than to die from
cancer so that's the trade-off you carry
out have made during our billions of
years of evolution
long live organism age but they develop
cancer less because of this program
is it clear yes Sam yes absolutely so
senescence apoptosis I'm not even talk
about apoptosis today p53 does two
things p53 tells us cells not to divide
which is senescence and in very severe
cases it tells the cells to kill cells
die it turns on a programs in which the
cell with that cells with too much DNA
damage that's in reparable will die so
you can see that p53 is a really
important program so what do you think
happens when a patient have no p53 what
do you think when a patient is born
without fever III yes yes go ahead
[Music]
exactly so what happens when you have
yourself in the middle with a lot of
damage what didn't happen
would you get cancer or no cancer yes
you here's this little girls that's
absolutely right so if you don't have
people v3 you can accumulate all these
DNA damage and you're gonna get cancer
at a very early age and in fact we have
patients Khalif for many patients who
inherited unfortunately a copy of mutant
p53 from their parents and then one copy
that's normal and when they copy or
normal people through is mutated when
you've lost both happier people you
through you can get cancer at the age of
18 months really young age to get cancer
right so p53 is absolutely important in
fact 80% of our human tumors all lose
p53 so if you look at human cancer this
gene is mutated it's gone but it takes a
long time to mutate it that's why we age
we get cancer late in life because it
takes a lot to get cancer you need to
have DNA damage from short telomeres you
need to have people if you law so short
generated myself is not an important
enough lots of people are three by self
is not enough only with this combination
the synergy of telomere dysfunction and
p53 loss do you get on the pathway to
cancer yes you guys [ __ ] I can't hear
you
actually that's a very good thought but
she doesn't have that people is really
so normally you lose people's doing with
your old LCD not inherently mutation P
versus our previous theory is actually
normal
okay so I told you a lot about cell
culture work what about in an organism
so when I was in my postdoc days we
actually made a mouse in which we'd
knocked out the telomerase gene so
here's a mouse with no telomerase in
every one of their tissues so what
happens is that the telomeres shorten as
we predict and look at this mouse this
is a mouse a very short telomere it
looks weird right it actually has a e/g
phenotype perhaps like this humpback it
loses his hair and it dies very early so
this is a director and here's the
telomere length so if you look at normal
telomeres it's like sort of like a
Gaussian distribution a normal
distribution and the clusters around
here this is around 5,000 units that's
long that's normal telomere if you don't
have the Plummers gene the telomeres
shorten right so your telomeres are
short so this is the first direct proof
that telomerase is needed to maintain an
organism's health span if you don't have
the enzyme telomerase like in this mouse
all the stem cells don't work well
that's why these mice age and the short
telomeres activate p53 to cause an aging
phenotype so this is direct proof in a
mouse in animal model and it's likely to
be true in humans obviously we can't
experiment this is the best we could do
but this mouse show signs of premature
aging due to telomere dysfunction
now what happens let's see how smart you
guys are because I think you guys are
pretty smart what happens if I mutate
p53 in this mouse
now this mouse is there are short
telomeres and there's no p53 whatever
you think happened
I mean your are your sizes yes okay
cancer yes so in fact these mice do
short telomeres and no people three get
cancer very early now you have a way of
DNA damage fusions and no p33 as
guardian of that you're gonna get cancer
absolutely okay so I'm gonna summarize
this part of the talk with this diagram
making aging cancer and telomeres so you
guys should all know this because just
what I'm talking about
in normal somatic cells with no
telomerase telomere shortening with each
round of cell division right this is a
that's what's happening right now with
us so very short telomeres is viewed as
damaged DNA damaged DNA activates p53
which is a sensor for damaged DNA it's a
guarding of the genome so when people in
3 gets activated it turns on the
senescence program to tell the cells to
stop dividing this is a good thing
because these cells with short telomeres
and damaged DNA will if they don't stop
the valley they will give rise to cancer
so p53 is blocking cancer by telling
these mutated DNA damage style to stop
dividing what if you unfortunately lose
p53 in in the cell then remember genes
are mutated stochastically all the time
I mean random mutations happen if you
just are unlucky that you really have a
cell that loses people through this is
what happens telomeres are shortened but
the short telomeres will not activate a
protective program like senescence the
cells will continue to shorten the
telomeres and in fact what would they
would happen is they will reactivate
telomerase that's given enough time
telomeres will maintain the telomeres
and cancer cells these cells will become
cancerous now they have telomerase that
have short telomeres no people a 3 again
us that kid right there predicted or
you're the little girl predicted sorry
cancer progression right so you have to
flip sides of the coin either you let
you age or you get answer you can't have
your cake a tin - of course we do we do
link this two together right you age
cancer happens as we age as because it
takes time to show in your telomeres and
to lose your p53 and so this is given by
this graph here so this is the incidence
of cancer with age though as you know
cancer increases with age right so
Elsie's are very aberrant phenomena it's
don't get cancer cancer we know is
associated with advancing age and in
older adults and that's because
telomeres shorten right so you have this
threshold we get very short telomeres
and
has instance and that's when cancer
occurs yes yep yes short telomeres is
not the only way to get mutation I'm
obviously focusing on that because
that's my research but you can mutate
DNA in many other ways as well as long
as you damage DNA and you also lose p53
you will get cancer okay so let me show
you some human data so these are people
that we follow not we but the collective
we so here's cancer incidence so people
with the shorter telomeres have the
highest cancer incidence people just
happen to have longer telomeres have
much lower cancers and look at the
difference especially with follow-up in
terms of month this is like a five fold
difference
so hopefully every one of us here have
long telomeres right so it's protective
so look at cancer death so death from
cancer
so again segregated from the shortest
telomeres with the longest period look
at this rate of death it's like a
tenfold difference if you have very
short telomeres you're gonna die from
cancer at ten times higher frequency
than with those with long telomeres
again you're born either with long short
telomeres is nothing really you can do
about it so this is this is
unfortunately this is just a random
thing so look at this look at this
progression so actually there are a lot
of companies now you probably have seen
some on CNN that are actually testing
for telomere length not that they could
do anything about it but it could just
tell you okay you have long telomeres or
short telomeres I'm not sure what that
information is gonna help you with but
you know this is not like we could go
and extend our telomeres okay so then
what's happening here is so if you look
at Plataea million for the age all of us
are doing something like this right our
telomeres are shortening you know
somehow we're gonna get to some kind of
threshold with disease risk is going up
and that's when we get cancer that's
what cancer happens around 70 or so
years of age but there are some people
you can imagine with mutations and
telomerase so what do you think is gonna
happen with those people if you have
mutations in the genes that encode
farmers actually here is kilometers and
work what do you think is gonna happen
to those people yes
exactly so this is the rate for
mutations and people with telomerase so
they're gonna hit the disease risk and
around 30 years or so of age
you know just hypothetically right
because their slope is much sharper than
this guy
so here's us we're gonna hit disease
wreck around 70 they're gonna hit it at
30 and in fact we can actually do a
diagnostic and look at telomere lanes to
predict whether these people are gonna
be are gonna come down with diseases so
if we look at MMS telomeres length is
usually this Gaussian distribution a
normal distribution so here's for five
patients say she's one two three four
five okay so this patient this patient
and this patient all have somewhat of
normal telomere length or drew a red
line through it this patient have just
longer telomere length is on to shifted
to the to the right look at this guy
this guy has short telomeres and in fact
very short telomeres we look we use
other measures to look at the length of
the telomeres and in fact they have much
shorter telomeres and the other patients
of the four patients and in fact the
number of chromosome with very short
telomeres is about four times higher
okay so you can see this is actually a
molecular diagnosis that you could do
for patients so this patient with a
short telomeres actually has a disease
called the scare ptosis congenital and
it's a weird name
these patients have very strange day of
phenotype they have like you know
plaques in their mouth but the worst
thing they have is they have bone marrow
failure
remember bone marrows are the fastest
dividing components of your body you can
imagine that these are the components
are gonna show on the telomeres first
because they're dividing so fast
especially you have an infection you're
gonna rev up your bone marrow right to
produce all those my blood cells so
these patients come to us at 30 years of
age with bone marrow failure and they
also get cancer it's called
AML they have this type of cancer and I
have this think of for Palmeri fibrosis
and if you measure the telomere length
they're all shorter than even one
percentile
this is the plot of telomere length
normally you're here somewhere and these
are the patient's very short telomeres
so sure telomeres are type of
and Rome and it can cause causes disease
they actually have aging phenotype
cancer and they die very early so what
we would love to do as clinicians is to
be able to move the disease progression
up so now I told you that telomeres are
shortening like this so what if we could
delay that shortening what if we could
instead of seven years of age let's
delay it to 100 years of age could we do
something like that what do you guys
think Sam I don't believe that data
that's it
that data is end of one eye and my
colleague did I did I totally don't
believe it okay you can't conclude
anything remember invest scientist was
end of one one sample if you have a
hundred cosmonauts or astronauts and you
show delay telomere loss I'll buy them
not within a one even if you have a twin
control study no no no no okay so I
don't like the idea but there's
something that we can do I already told
you there's something that potentially
we could do to increase telomere length
what could we do to increase telomere
length telomerase see this kid's been
listening
what are you introduce telomerase that
wasn't you know people would be talking
about this we discovered telomerase what
about giving kilometers to people to
increase their telomere length wouldn't
that shift the axis up to prevent aging
okay so we give two llamas two cells so
here's an asset for Tommy that I got to
talk into it but remember I told you
that I showed you telomeres and smears
ready to get shorter shorter to eight
look what happens if you put in
telomerase telomeres get longer it
really does lengthen telomeres an enzyme
is working especially a high copies look
telomeres are increasing
remember it's T cells siness a 60
population doubling 60 passages this is
what normally without telomerase they
stop dividing with telomerase they're
immortal they're growing growing growing
is not a good thing why is why isn't why
do some people say no it's not a good
thing
well yeah you three I only call our
youth how about you in the back
yes speak up yes telomers have the
undesirable side effect or promoting
cancer so again you can't have your cake
and eat it as well so here is the good
and bad thing about having telomerase so
yes if you add in promise you do slow
telomere rate loss you do improve your
immune system we've demonstrated this in
mouse models you can slow down this
break is fusion generating fusion genes
like we that we see in LC you do
activate renewal and you do reduce
senescence so aging is reduced but the
flipside is increased cancer incidence
because now you're favoring any cell
with mutations to live right because
you're in down them with immortality and
if they lose p53 forget it you're gonna
get cancer yes if you increase it so
actually the biggest mutation in for
cancer is cell division so you don't
want to increase cell then you want to
decrease our division but then you then
you can't grow oh yeah that would be
docile that's the Holy Grail if you
become an adult if you can manipulate
people to 3 levels we could maintain
manipulate cell division levels that'll
be fantastic we can't do that cell
division is a number one generation of
mutations because when we replicate our
DNA we there's errors that's made it's
not just from telomere dysfunction but
errors in DNA replication contribute to
cancer pathogenesis and as I said every
time you divide your showing your
telomeres
okay so giving to omurice in theory is a
good thing but in practice is probably
not gonna be if they approve because of
this risk you don't want to give
something that you know may have
marginal effect in terms of a
lengthening the age of people but then
you will have to run the risk of getting
cancer right you don't want to do that
okay so my final slide is a summary or
what I talked about
so telomeres shorten with normal aging
right with each round the cell division
or you have premature aging syndrome
like this keratosis congenita that
people are born without that enzyme
telomerase their telomeres are shortened
and the short telomeres activate a DNA
damage response damaged DNA it's just
like any other damaged DNA from ionizing
radiation chemotherapy or whatever
it activates a p53 dependent checkpoint
remember p53 and be any damage so if you
have p53 in your cells which you know
all of us hopefully do p53 will sense
this damaged DNA telomere dysfunction
and says okay you're gonna stop dividing
because that the further you divide
you're gonna become cancerous and that's
not good for the organism so they
undergo senescence and it can also
trigger apoptosis as Sam alluded to
which I'm not going to talk about but
both of these processes can contribute
to an aging phenotype that's what we age
okay but if your cells have no p53 just
by randomly lost people three we are 75
years of age that one cell is gonna have
the endowment of short telomeres no
people three to check the DNA damage
response on the gold is crazy breakage
fuse your bridge cycle leading to gene
fusions like we saw an LC cancer
happening now somebody asked me I think
was you why that's LC being a
fifteen-year-old does she have broken
DNA that took that happens you have
fusions that occur right normally I have
been telling you that this only happens
where you're like an old person
the reason being as I said telomere
lengths are inherited some people are
endowed with short telomeres in Elsie's
case she just had unfortunately shorter
telomeres are normal and that's what
gave rise to this type of fusion and I
think you asked a question of this is
whether this is the 1517 is not random
and is not the reason why this
chromosome translocation is not random
it's like chromosomes live in
territories in the nucleus so chromosome
15 is something just happy to live near
each other so when there's a break they
just happen to join with each other
okay so that's what you don't see
chromosome 1 and 15 making this type of
cancer it's always 1570 because they
live near each other and if you're near
next to your neighbor you're going to be
able to fuse easier okay so this is the
link between aging and cancer and it's
all due to telomere shortening and the
p53 checkpoint thank you very much for
your questions I love it and I'll take
any more questions if you like there's
some great questions amazing
[Music]